entendre tous ceux qui ont quelque chose
à dire sur cet article 24 la conférence
des procureurs
les directions du ministre à la justice
ou le ministère de l'intérieur
des universitaires tout un tas de
personnes qui peuvent avoir quelque
chose d'intéressant à nous dire et
surtout à a proposé une rédaction mieux
caler juridiquement problème pour vous
aujourd'hui de façon claire d'abord est
ce que l'article est utile est ce que
l'article protège tout le monde on parle
des gendarmes et des policiers
est ce que demain un instituteur un élu
local
un magistrat sera de la même manière
protégée par cet article est-ce qu'il
est au bon endroit
est-ce qu'il faut toucher à la loi de
1881 ou est ce qu'il faut le mettre en
dur dans le code pénal
est ce que en le mettant dans le code
pénal on ne crée pas un renforcement des
sanctions à l'égard des auteurs qui
serait peut-être trop importante par
rapport aux importants par rapport à
l'objectif que l'on veut atteindre enfin
tout est question qu'on se pose avec
marc philippe daubresse qu'on se pose
ouvertement qu'ils sont des questions
qui sont sur la table on est éclairé par
tous ceux qui ont quelque chose à nous à
nous expliquer et donc on fait
simplement notre travail de deux
parlementaires j'ai commencé par dire on
se demande s'il est utile est ce qu'il
faudrait pas tout simplement le
supprimer il ya un article 25 dans le
projet de loi séparatisme qui est très
proche de cet article 24
est-ce que c'est nécessaire d'avoir deux
articles presque là qu'est la question
se pose exactement dans les temps que
vous évoquez car effectivement il une
polarisation sur sa taille 24 qui était
une modification de la loi de 1881 sur
la liberté de la presse et que l'on peut
se poser la question de savoir si le
droit positif actuel pénale ne répond
pas en tout ou partie à la question et
si si ça n'est que partielle à ce moment
là il faut envisager peut-être de
renforcer l'arsenal pénal
[Musique]